if you're thinking of starting a new
business make sure it's around something
that you love doing and you know will
help a lot of people
otherwise you're going to end up
failing
broke and having to go back and get
another job
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
today i'm answering a question from a
youtube viewer love your youtube guys
mo
and mo wrote in to say evan if you're
not good at anything in particular but
you know in your heart you want to own
your own business how do you figure out
exactly what to go for if you don't have
a talent to capitalize on
great question mo thanks for asking it
and i believe that everybody has
talent and skills and passion for
something you just have to tap into it
if you're not sure what you want to do
yet
my recommendation is to go out
and make a list of all the things that
you love doing and that helps people if
you want to have success as an
entrepreneur you've got to love your
business you've got to do it even if
you're not getting paid to do it you've
got to run through brick walls because
it's going to be hard
and it has to help people
people have to have a problem that you
are solving for them
if you can merge those two something
that you love doing with something that
helps a lot of people in a really great
way
that is the core of a successful
business that you can start
if you are you know still planning that
out that's fine it's an exciting place
to be it's a great time to be writing in
and asking questions
start talking to potential customers see
what their feedback is
see how you can help them
and if you've never started a business
before
before going out and launching your own
what i would recommend is go work for
somebody else
go find somebody who's doing exactly
what you're doing
somebody who has experience who's built
up their business to five or ten
employees
somebody who you respect go work for
them learn the business learn the
industry learn what it takes to be an
entrepreneur you'll make all your
mistakes while getting paid to do it
you'll make industry contacts you'll
learn how that company operates and when
you go launch your own business you'll
have a lot of the things lined up where
most entrepreneurs
don't do that and end up failing
but right where you are if you're trying
to figure out what your passion is
start by thinking about the things that
you can get lost in things that you
could do all day long you wake up you're
excited to do it it's eight in the
morning
you're working away
you look up and it's five o'clock at
night you've gotten lost in it you love
doing it so much
and then think about how that could help
people
for me
i love helping entrepreneurs and i love
researching
famous entrepreneurs stories and how
they got started if i'm reading a
biography or the story of
of how some entrepreneur got started i
can get lost in it i can spend hours
doing it and and realize oh my god i
just lost so much time doing this i got
to get back to work
so turn that into work when i'm helping
entrepreneurs i often lose track of time
because i'm helping them i love helping
them it brings me so much happiness and
i might overrun some other things that i
was supposed to do
that's when you know you found something
that you're excited about
apply that plus the ability to help
people and you are on your way to making
a successful business
good luck write back to me when you
figured it out and we can help you get
to the next step for all that you
watching if you like the video please
give it a thumbs up below and hey i want
to hear from you too please leave a
comment below it really makes my day
when i see those come in if you have a
comment about this video or question for
your own business leave it below and i
will write back thank you guys i'll see
you soon